let me see your nails let me see those
nails nicole look at those now what's
going on there
so i got into fake nails i miss
having my long nails can't go to a salon
i refuse to die for my nails
so i ordered them online and they they
look pretty good they make me happy
you look fantastic can i see a close-up
of the uh it looks like there's
translucent ones
yes this one it's like see-through look
at that
it almost looks like you could have
little goldfish in there swimming around
i wish because then i could take my
little pet goldfish everywhere with me
let me ask you a question
why is it that women get to do that but
men can't i mean why can't
i get fake nails conan you can
get fake nails gender is a construct
uh gendered clothing is insane you can
wear
whatever you want promise all right you
know what i'm gonna do
you funny but just go hello i'm conan
o'brien
i'm thriving i'm doing well i want fake
nails and i'm living
you know what next time that you and i
are together in the same space
i want to get fake nails put on we'll do
that
you want me fully in drag yeah heels and
everything you'd be the tallest drag
queen
you've also got a nice slender body so
clothing would just hang off of you
you've got a full head of hair so maybe
we could do like a little like a short
maybe slick do
i i see it for you so you think i'd make
a great drag queen
yes i think you'd be stunning i actually
might be a lot more attractive
in drag i think it's kind of cool you
gotta stop with this whole
self-deprecating thing
you're stunning you have all of your
teeth your skin is so
smooth and you have two eyes
thank you for setting the lowest bar
ever
for me nicole
you have functioning eyes your ocular
jelly is in the orbits and it's
functioning
so you're gorgeous yes you're right well
you've pumped me up i now think i'm a
male model so thank you very much for
that